yeah hello and welcome to this video I
have screwed up the screen it stayed a
little bit and took me a while to have
to it start the video so I'm down a
couple of seconds yeah playing a super
saw Charlotte mark back which I'm not
mark berkovich this is right yes so
let's see what happens here this is a
line that I do play b5 and d5 I always
feel like I should know it better than I
actually do but I'm sir going for it it
makes an awful lot of sense to me to
prevent c4 but I sometimes feel like I'm
not playing it right yeah I development
is just a little bit off but ok we'll
see what happens in this game yeah white
is a lot better developed actually but
he also has weakened the screen side so
I'm not sure about this kind of setup
maybe a quickie force hitting me some
night you 584 or yeah something like
that hmm yeah yeah I wanted to get my
king site going ie4 could be could be an
issue opening up the position name and
he's going for it hmm I am taking and
screwing up cancelling rights is very
dangerous and my long diagonal is more
than shaky so probably do this even
though it looks quite cheeky that whole
business I met I'm really happy that
there is no Queen a4 yeah that would
probably be absolutely fatal ok so I
don't don't know if that is so dangerous
really let's go back is it dangerous um
if he is not if he doesn't find some
kind of direct crush year then I'm okay
I'm really okay his Queen side po
information is somewhat devalued there
with a form weakling the be four square
so it doesn't seem to be too bad yes hmm
I was thinking about this this kind of
move but I didn't think it is so
dangerous I'm not behind the development
anymore which is very very reassuring
yum i can actually play Queen B 6 there
is no direct problem with that I think
I'll do I mean Queen takes pawn takes
it's not ideal but I don't know how else
to cover be seven and I don't want to
lose time maybe Bishop a6 was a move
actually oh ok I maybe I should have
thought about this a little bit longer I
mean this feels okay but yeah anyway
yeah it's gotten that one in and that's
what that isn't something that I needed
to allow necessarily anyway anyway I
don't think I mean in bad shape
now be one what else be 595 I'm happy
with I think yes so he's going with this
i karouk th he's got night be five
don't see anything great yet to be
honest night to be five well with the
night on b5 is not going to move the
pawns anytime soon so then but 97 is on
hmm I'm not quite sure what to do
yeah I don't feel um I'm dangerous so
much but I don't I didn't see a great
continuation yeah this is I don't think
it's too much still ok so i can grab so
legally five yeah ok it's a five coming
here I don't know I can do I can do this
to stop a five for the moment
night c4e i was wondering if b 5 is a
move growl our third is offering a draw
ok I don't know I'm down on time it's
tough to tough to not take it actually
or did he make some kind of mistake that
I'm not not currently seeing how to
exploit I don't see it it's bit lame but
I didn't see a good move really and I'm
down one minute um yeah well I've lost
many games by continuing in situations
like that and I think overall I lost
more points than i won so maybe this is
just a wise decision for once yeah here
I felt I'm okay but difficult to to make
anything out of it I mean no I'm not
saying I'm better so I but it just that
I didn't really see anything anything we
can try for more rook c4 maybe but I
wasn't sure if he can go away 5 and 12
that's a pawn I mean it just it's a
passer I probably can't stop it somehow
yeah but it didn't feel right I think
what I did was was ok but here I was
briefly thinking about this but this is
one of those ups I'm sorry one of those
moves that can easily lend you in huge
trouble this kind of thing I was
thinking about but after this I'm losing
there's this threat and b6 and yeah so
that is not a way to to continue
probably something like that
I mean that I can play I mean not that
I'm better or so but it's a way to
decline the draw probably equal I'm
interested a little bit also in the
opening where I was so much down in
development but ok so Bishop e7 TX tix
if I it looks dangerous it really does
look dangerous should be seven yeah the
engine is giving Bishop g5 with the very
clear advantage yeah my development is
not good here it really isn't after that
yeah probably have to go here and this
looks pretty awful and yeah I've lost
too much time in the opening maybe you
know the engine is giving this move
which has the clear point of attacking
that rook what can take the one
sacrifice it for very interesting play
but that doesn't feel completely clear
yeah maybe am maybe I have to play
differently here to be better prepared
prepared for the e4 push like this for
example this is what stockfish is giving
after this I can take I'm a full tempo
up let's say this is also worth
something yeah maybe something something
there yeah I'm in trouble not yets it's
ok i think yeah I'm okay but I was a
very shaky position in the opening ok
well thanks for watching